d'après les premiers éléments d'enquêté
les normes de sécurité semblent avoir
été respectée au parc astérix ou un
enfant de 6 ans s'est noyé hier
le garçonnet est tombé d'une grosse
bouée à bord de laquelle ils avaient
pris place avec un groupe de personnes
pour des va lire une rivière ponctuée de
cascades d'ormuz et de geysers
l'attraction a été placé sous scellés
franck petit a songé
après avoir été brièvement pris en
charge par une cellule psychologique
les enfants repartent chez eux en
belgique escorté par les motards de la
gendarmerie
les petits de 6 ans choquée par les
événements de l'après midi l'un des
leurs julien est passé par dessus bord
alors qu'il profitait de cette
attraction filmé ici en 2004
l'accident s'est produit à 15h38 il aura
fallu près de 20 minutes pour retrouver
le garçonnet et qu'on a su que l'enfant
était un lieu où on a on s'est précipité
tous ceux qui étaient sur place
aussi les opérateurs qui s'occupe de
l'attraction que que l'encadrement qui
n'est jamais très très loin à sauter
directement pour essayer de retrouver
et puis de le remonter à la surface puis
possible et donc l'eau était trouble qui
n'a pas tout vu tout de suite retrouvé
on n'a pas retrouvé tout de suite
malheureusement et c'est un set au pied
d'un de la traction à la
dans dans l'eau on l'a pas retrouvée
depuis le lot n'est pas effectivement
les parents du petit julien sont arrivés
hier à l'hôpital de creil où a été
transporté leurs enfants à l'entrée du
parc astérix le règlement intérieur
précise que la direction engage vivement
les parents à ne pas laisser les enfants
de moins de 12 ans sans la surveillance
d'un adulte
à défaut sa responsabilité ne saurait
être engagée malgré tout une enquête
pénale a été ouverte par le procureur de
senlis
y at il eu défaut de surveillance de la
part des adultes qui encadraient les
enfants les procédures de sécurité
ont-elles fonctionner correctement
pour l'instant des investigations se
poursuivent beaucoup d'auditions
évidemment puisqu'il y avait beaucoup de
personnes présentes pour définir les
chefs conscience de ce drame
en attendant les résultats de l'enquêté
la traction qui existe depuis
l'ouverture du parc a été mise sous
scellés